[Rires]
visiblement
visiblement les individus ce serait
introduit avec un camion benne dans le
rectum de la
visiblement c'est qui
[Applaudissements]
je vous en fais deux
visiblement les individus donc ce sont
introduits dans le rectum du Nord
personne donc susnommé oui effectivement
la personne donc j'ai eu les copains de
la diversité
la personne
[Applaudissements]
que les personnes de la PDF
de la pire PCJ de Lille Roubaix
donc la personne va être donc gardé avec
lui
est-ce que ça veut dire donc c'est une
personne que tu te contrôle oculaire
d'une autre personne ayant dit c'est
Nice aux deux yeux cette personne va
être déféré apparemment chez Bruno
stipolati
le canards
oui visiblement Bruno
les personnes seront déféré
éventuellement demain effectivement nous
différencer ça veut dire que donc les
personnes vont être présentés devant un
Japonais
donc et donc ces personnes vont être
peut-être incarcérées incarcéré ça veut
dire donc mis en incarcération
et donc quand on parle pas de Gilles
Verdez donc le chroniqueur bien connu
qui donc lui serait
[Rires]
incarcération donc prisonnier entre
quatre murs bien entendu une tierce
personne
[Applaudissements]
avec les équipes avec mon avec mes amis
et toutes les équipes vous avez préparé
la séquence
en fait il fait ça toute la journée
vocales aux équipes ah bon en fait
Mathieu c'est de s'envoyer de ses notes
vocales en imitant des personnes de
l'émission j'en ai un autre
[Musique]
[Rires]
je l'adore la personne dont est arrivé
c'est Michel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est donc arrivé à 8h42 donc 8h40
et donc on va faire je pense qu'on va
faire on va parodie nous-mêmes
je vais faire Mireille
je suis au niveau libre aussi
[Applaudissements]
et on a joué un foot au foot un jour
avec Olivier
sont en vacances
et au niveau libre
dans les manifs les meilleurs dans les
manifs que sur le terrain
donc un moment on a fait un match donc
il était contre nous il avait raison et
moi et d'autres personnes je crois qu'on
leur a mis 10 ans
et après ils nous ont donné au niveau
livre
en avoir fait on a marché
il joue pas mal non
toi tu joues aussi bien je suis le
renard des surfaces
comment tu l'as trouvé c'est bien sur le
côté bien sûr
et j'ai marqué 3 buts
devant
je suis comique comme ça
en haut à droite et il bouge pas et
vraiment très fort les gars j'étais au
pub quand je te donne et c'est là que
moi j'ai vu qu'il y avait rien ils ont
joué une heure j'ai dit et franchement
et Raymond il est monstrueux j'étais
mort non non
c'est déjà fini elle était en apnée
il dit alors on fait quoi en or fin j'ai
ça y est on a fait une heure à fond on
va manger là